this is a very tough audience we've got
steve cohen who's connected to everybody
in media we've got eric and jay who's
who's recorded
thousands of rappers now the
adrenaline's pumping ah
don't mess this up chris it's your one
shot
so so do do your thing okay so freestyle
rap um
so we're gonna take some suggestions so
if you have one raise your
yes yeah venus
volcanism so i know what venus is
volcanism is this a star trek thing no
what is it
the oh oh volcanism okay sorry okay
cool cool so volcanic activities on
on the planet venus amazing that's a
great suggestion okay let's get another
one
playstations yeah boy i like it i like
it
do you have a particular favorite sorry
do you have a particular favorite
like which which console oh game okay
got a wall cool cool we can do that
malaysia malaysia nice
malaysia playstation with focusing on
god of war
and volcanoes on venus james i gotta say
the james alter show
so so egotistical okay
cool um this then will be
hey see people are gonna think like oh
he probably expected he'd say that no i
didn't
no i didn't uh this would be a freestyle
rap that's right made up on the spot
base and all those things
uh venus volcanism the playstation and
god of war
malaysia and the james altucher show and
it's it's completely improvised
completely unscripted and never to be
seen again
and if we drop that beat let's uh do
this
it's coming in
if we can pump it a little bit louder as
well please this is the tension it's
building
these little synths rats you never seen
this let me spit off hot
like i go on venus blowing out the cold
air look
down below i'm a pyroclastic flow on the
volcano even though it's got no
atmosphere even when i'm up here the
sulfur in the air make sure you stand
clear sulphurous like a fart when i'm
eating beans
volcanic activity the lights are which
you've never seen before
i am one past mercury i'd like to spin
around yeah
don't desert me my knowledge about the
solar system
punch hard like a piston yeah you might
think i miss them the planets
but i never plan it though i make it up
malleable like the play-doh
you can see me erupting like saint
helens
mount helena vesuvius i go better i move
over words never phase you i'm in kl
kuala lumpur in malaysia
i'm with my friends i'm feeling so
pretty people in singapore think you're
shitty but
i disagree i like the country if i say
anything about the monarchy they're on
the hunt for me
they will send for the royal guard yes
you know i got
censored when i went to malaysia i did a
great show
but before the thing yes they wanted to
know i had to write my whole routine out
which is hard cause words just spit out
i didn't say
anything about the king of the queen
which was so damn lucky it would have
been obscene they would
have clapped me an eye and tongue me
upside down but at least
you can spit chewy on the town in
singapore the chewing gum goes down low
it's fun to be here on the j.a show i'll
touch her like i'm touching the birds
that move
their heads 180 and observe that's an
i'll touch a bun
i knew i had one for you it's really
cool yeah
not a lawyer but got the mind of one
learning new things
you wanna tell comedy you wanna spew
things like jokes so you're buying the
comedy club
all the guests coming on yeah getting
that rub it's a handshake
sitting round all the table podcast bro
on the mugs i'm
able wearing a shirt with your own brand
on
this is so nice call me brandon dick
camillo cause i got the freestyle flow
he was a great rapper from cky
years ago that was the jackass relation
last one i'm sitting back playing
playstation and one thing
you know i am the boss the button's not
an x the button is across
isn't that weird when they came out with
the fact we know the circle square and
triangle they're taking it back i like
to play those games
the ones that are easier i like to play
sports mlb and fifa but the one
is the best number four after the first
trilogy we had the god of war
it's kratos and his son go to find the
gods i've only played the third one but
what a fit bod he had in that
having sex with aphrodite goddess of
beauty vagina real tighty
try and keep it nicely but now he's much
older getting all the money getting all
of the gold they're like ambrosia yeah
that's the food of the deities
when they're on olympus oh what a
travesty if the giants come up and bring
them back down
i brought my playstation to the new york
town i play it in my hotel room
so much modern media that i consume and
now we got the ps plus in november the
game's outlast two yeah you should
remember what a weird thing to end a
wrap on
the ps plus game that is coming up in
november it's outlast two
and i believe a game set in feudal japan
where you are a samurai i can't remember
the name of that one
um that was that rap there yeah
great thank you stacking it with a
knowledge rather than punchlines and so
just
just each line you're like uh
you know before you start the line you
don't know where you're gonna no people
are like oh it's so amazing how you can
think ahead i never think ahead
it just it just comes up